the school of architecture that I
studied at some thirty years ago
happened to be across the street from
the wonderful art gallery designed by
the Great Architect Louie Kahn I love
that building and I used to visit it
quite often and one day I saw the
security guard run his hand across the
concrete wall and it was the way he did
it the expression on his face something
touched me I could see that the security
guard was moved by the building and that
architecture has that capacity to move
you I could see it and I remember
thinking wow how does architecture do
that at school I was learning to design
but here here was a reaction of the
heart and it touched me to the core you
know you aspire for beauty for
sensuousness for atmosphere the
emotional response that's the realm of
the ineffable and the immeasurable and
that's what you live for a chance to try
so in 2003 there was an open call for
designs for the Baha'i temple for South
America this was the first temple in all
of South America it's a continental
temple a hugely important milestone for
the Baha'i community because this would
be the last of the Continental temples
and would open the door for national
local temples to be built around the
world and the brief was deceptively
simple and unique in the annals of
religion a circular room
nine sides nine entrances nine pass
allowing you to come to the temple from
all directions nine symbolizing
completeness perfection no pulpit no
sermons as there no clergy in the Baha'i
faith and in a world which is putting up
walls the design need to express in form
the very opposite it had to be open
welcoming to people of all faiths walks
of life backgrounds or no no faith at
all a new form of sacred space with no
pattern or models to draw from it was
like designing one of the first churches
for Christianity or one of the first
mosques for Islam so we live in a
secular world how do you design sacred
space today and how do you even define
what's sacred today I stumbled across
this beautiful quote from the Baha'i
writings and it speaks to prayer it says
that if you reach out in prayer and if
your prayer is answered which is already
very interesting that the pillars of
your heart will become a shine and I
love this idea of the inner and the
outer like when you see someone and you
say that person is radiant and I was
thinking my gosh how could we make some
something architectural out of that
where you'd love that where you create a
building and it becomes alive with light
like alabaster if you kiss it with light
it becomes alive and I drew this sketch
something with two layers translucent
with structure in between capturing
light maybe a pure form a single form of
emanation that you could imagine would
be all dome and everything we kept
making was looking too much like an egg
a blob so you search you all know this
crazy search letting the process take
you and you live for the surprises and I
remember quite by accident saw this
little video of a plant moving in light
and it made me think of movement reach
this idea that the temple could have
reached at this reach for the divine you
can imagine also that movement within a
circle could mean movement and stillness
like the cosmos something that you see
in many places but rotation was not
enough because we needed a form and in
the Baha'i writings it talks about the
temples being as perfect as is humanly
possible and we kept thinking well what
is perfection I remember I stumbled into
this image of this Japanese basket and
thinking our Western notions of
perfection need to be challenged that
this wonderful silhouette of this basket
this wonkiness and that it has the kind
of dimple of ash of of what you might
imagine a shoulder or the cheekbone and
that kind of organic form and so we drew
and made models these lines that merge
at the top soft lines which became like
drapery and translucent veils and
folding and the idea of not only folding
but torquing you remember the plant and
the way that it was reaching and it
started to become an interesting for
carving the base making the entrances
and then then we ended up with this this
is this temple with two layers nine
luminous veils embodied light soft
flowing lines like luminescent drapery
180 submissions were received from 80
countries and this was selected so we
went to the next stage of how to build
it we had submitted alabaster but
alabaster was too soft and we were
experimenting many experiments with
materials trying to think how we could
have this kind of shimmer and we ended
up with borosilicate and borosilicate
glasses you know is very strong and if
you break borosilicate rods just so and
melt them at just the right temperature
we ended up with this new material this
new cast glass which took us about two
years to make and it had this quality
that we love this idea of the embodied
light but on the inside we wanted
something with a soft light like the
inner lining of a jacket on the outside
you have protection but on the inside
you touch it so we found this tiny vein
in a huge quarry in Portugal with this
beautiful stone which the owner had kept
for seven generations in this family
waiting for the right project you can
believe it look at this material it's
beautiful and the way it lights up and
it has that translucent quality so here
you see the structure lets the light
through and looking down the nine wings
are bound structurally but symbolically
strong a great symbol of unity pure
geometry perfect circle 30 metres in
section
and in plan perfectly symmetrical like
the idea of sacredness and geometry and
here you see the building going up mm
steel nodes 9,000 pieces of steel 7800
stone pieces 10,000 cast glass pieces
all individual shapes the entire
superstructure all described engineered
fabricated with aerospace technology
prefabricated machined the machine
robotically a huge team effort you can
imagine literally hundreds and within 3%
of our 30 million dollar budget set in
2006 nine wings bound together forming a
nine pointed star and the star shape
moving in space tracking the Sun
[Music]
so here it is hopefully a befitting
response to that beautiful quote a
prayer answered open in all directions
capturing the blue light of dawn
tent-like white light of day the gold
light of the afternoon and of course at
night the reversal sensuous catching the
light in all kinds of mysterious ways
and the sight it's interesting 14 years
ago when we made the submission we show
the temple set against the Andes we
didn't have the Andes as our site but
after nine years that's exactly where we
ended up the lines of the temple set
against nothing but pure nature and you
turn around and you get nothing but the
city below you and inside of you in all
directions radiating gardens from each
of the alcoves radiating paths last
October the opening ceremonies a
beautiful sacred event 5,000 people from
80 countries a continuous River of
visitors indigenous people from all over
South America some who had never left
their villages and of course that this
temple belongs to people the collective
of many cultures and walks of life many
beliefs and for me what's most important
is what it feels like on the inside
that it feel intimate sacred and that
everyone is welcome and if even a few
who come have the same reaction as that
security guard then it truly would be
their temple and I would love that thank
you
[Applause]